people i travel with collider and i am
thrilled to be with part of the cast of
mythicquest uh i love your show i want
to thank you so much for coming in but i
guess i'm going to start with the most
important question are you guys cool
with him standing on an apple crate
during the end
it is a really difficult ego and we just
try to make make do with what we can
so here's the thing um it's
i don't know how many for each of you
have you been to comic-con before is
this like can you sort of talk about
that
yeah i mean i'm i have been here so many
times i you know i'm i'm kind of part of
the nerd business since i was like 18 so
i've been here a few times um probably
the biggest thing i did here was
moderating the adventure time panel the
last one that was here that was really
cool i watched that online it was really
cool
if i was a better journalist i would
know this information prior to asking
that but let's just pretend you know i'm
i'm messing around but
for you guys i know i know
got a real span here because we've got
veterans and first-timers and it's it's
been nice to get to lean on ashley and
danny have you been to comicon before
once but i didn't really get to
experience it i was here for work and i
just
popped into onto the floor for a few
minutes and felt very overwhelmed and
then i was like okay that's enough
but it's a it's a really great community
so yeah jumping into actually the show
um i believe you guys and i don't know
but you have wrapped the next season or
you yes so how long ago did you guys
actually rap
many times
ago
yeah yeah
so what are you allowed to actually
tease about the new season what can i
expect we are in it
all four of
us happen miracles there's eye contact
there's eye contact they're words and
comedy our characters have developed
there's growth arcs mini arcs big arcs
media marks peaks and valleys bathroom
scenes conference room scenes conflict
there is some conflict
well listen one of the things that i
love about the show is one of the many
things is that it's really there can be
episodes that are very unexpected things
that really come out of left field and
i'm like oh my god that's so not what i
you know what i mean and so the writing
and i want to go into the writing it's
so good can you sort of talk about what
it's like getting those scripts for the
first time and um
i guess just talk a little bit about
that
ashley why i don't um i'm i'm on the
writing staff um so i feel like i
shouldn't answer this question
i will say reading the scripts it is
such a joy uh i think also coming into
the season now we all know our
characters pretty well too so it's so
fun to kind of jump into a season where
everything is just kind of flying and i
feel like especially the way our season
starts it's very much like every
character is very clear
and what their mission is and uh that
was just really fun so but the writing's
amazing on the show and it's uh
it's also very kind of like organic in
the process too everyone kind of jumps
in and and changes and helps and makes
it better which is really cool well
that's the thing like uh and a lot of
people i spoke to when you get to the
third season everyone that the writers
and everybody knows the voices so it's
so much clearer so it's it's how much
does that help like i guess on set are
you allowed as actors to like tweak
things are you thinking about it the
night before like maybe this is gonna be
an alt you know yeah yes we're
encouraged to i mean there's so much
rewriting happens just from improv on
the day i mean i think there's a scene
that you and i are in in the car there's
a car
spoiler
on
[Applause]
so there's certain things that like i
mean some of my favorite scenes i think
from previous seasons are people just
riffing yeah um which i think comes from
like the you know most the eps are sunny
people and there's so much improv and
sunny so it makes it really fun that
like you know that the script is a great
place to start and then if there's stuff
that you want to try it's not you know
it's going to be encouraged so it's not
like curb where it's like they get a
paragraph no no no no no you know what
i'm joking
you know so i love learning about like
the behind the scenes the making of a
show so for fans um what do you think
might surprise them to learn about like
the actual making of the series
we move very quickly i don't know if
that's a surprise but the way that we
can't even keep up we were so ahead of
schedule that they would sort of like
force us to take hiatus days because
they're like we need to slow down
we were supposed to rap like two weeks
after we wrapped this this past season
we were shooting so fast that they
didn't have time to do pre-production on
upcoming episodes yeah it was fun
we kept going home actors we love
because we get to go home and be with
our families and our partners and our
dogs and we're like we get to have
dinner after work so it's great i just
want to point this out and i want more
answers but for people that don't
actually understand the way tv works
this is not the norm
very rare
no one i know
has ever said that to me in all my
interviews it's really a testament to
rob mcelhoney and our crew it's about
balance and like family and it's so nice
when you're like oh i have a thing on
wednesday at six o'clock i can make my
daughter swim meat
that's uh that's never happened to me
before so it's really cool yeah yeah is
there anything else though about like
the behind the scenes that you think
might surprise people i would say the
whole crew is very talented
in a way where it's uh our you know how
it's filmed the dps the art department
um props everybody comes together really
cool it's like a family really is like a
family i think especially over the last
couple years we've really bonded because
it's been
you know there used to be people on sets
all the time and now it's just kind of
it's tighter right and so
uh it's been really cool to see how
everyone's really embraced that and
everyone just always adds a nice little
creative layer to whatever we're doing
so
it's fun to watch everybody work so
quickly you know
it's a well-oiled machine our shell
there
check it out just check it out as
someone who's on an apple show does that
mean you get an apple subscription for
life
nah
can we do something about this if you've
got the strings to pull i am not going
to stop could you yeah could you call
tim for us
we're before you want a side you want a
side hustle
getting into tim cook's good graces no
um
so going into the actual technical
making of the series you mentioned how
fast you work but typically is it
supposed to be like a seven day schedule
an eight day schedule what is it
actually like trying to do the episodes
i mean some episodes we shot well danny
and i directed the season and they were
phenomenal by the way this is surprising
things to learn
yeah i mean maybe we should have said
that in one of the previews
oh this is a sport isn't it that's
that's not that's not a spoiler
it's not a spoiler
wait wait
um it's okay
comedy but
scripted script is very different right
so uh yeah the episode i was directing
didn't have a lot of exterior locations
yeah it didn't have it was very uh set
in the office you know singular
locations two persons mostly two-person
scenes uh so it was
we've done it before and the way our
crew moves they know how to shoot it
they know how to light it yeah um so for
me it was wonderful to step into a role
new role uh but i felt like really
supported the whole time and um it was
just green they're all amazing and so
made my job super easy yeah my thing
though is when you are directing a show
that has a format how much do you
because obviously you're you can't
turn the ferrari so far
how much are you thinking about
like a camera shot that like you have
been waiting to do and you're like i've
been saving it for my episode
well i feel like you know you have to
have
the the script in mind obviously so it's
really for me like breaking down the
episode i directed is like what does it
call for and there's um a moment um
where there's more of a dramatic scene
where we went a little bit handheld
which our show doesn't typically do but
um we have a little bit of flexibility
and especially if the if it's sort of
not demanded by but like encouraged by
what's on the page so
it is nice i think also as first-time
directors to be like oh there's a
formula you have to follow i think it
would have been a little intimidating
otherwise but we also i felt like we had
room to play and try weird stuff you
know even within the confines of like
the set
aesthetic and i got to walk around and
we got to walk around with our dp uh
before and just kind of talk about the
scenes and you know um
it starts with the page it starts with
the scenes and the tone and and making
sure you have sort of those rails uh but
then you can kind of play a little and
be like i think for this scene maybe we
could try something new here uh we have
some
really cool locations so interior so you
can kind of play with the form a little
bit
um and we got to do that which was fun
and then you know you try it and then
people either say yes or no
uh how many episodes is this season
actually
ten
it's ten yeah yeah yeah big spoiler big
sport
big time spoilers
well one of the things that i think
makes the show so strong and other shows
that are like eight and ten episodes is
you're not and doing 22 or 26 where you
will have some weaker episodes i i love
the eight and ten episode format uh for
you guys can you sort of talk about that
aspect because every episode is so
strong
yeah i mean i think the cool thing about
being able to do
shorter runs also is that you get the
chance to craft an actual story that is
you know an arcs that you can track
throughout the season i feel like for
other you know back in the day of like
22 episodes it's kind of hard to build
that over the course of that many
episodes it becomes a bit more rinse and
repeat so for us we get to like
think about okay where are we heading
with all these characters you know what
do we want to build in we have these
episodes that can be sort of
self-contained but also serve a larger
story so in the writers room that's
really fun to think about like where do
we want poppy and i to end what do we
need to do to get there and all the
characters you know so i that's really
fun as a writer is to be able to build
those arcs in
there's an actor question so i'm
obviously at some point you play someone
who's doing something that you
completely disagree with
and
i'm not looking at anyone specifically
so i'm just curious what is it actually
like as an actor to play those scenes
where you're saying and doing things
that you're like oh my god i would never
do this is it fun is it liberating is it
can you sort of talk about that for me i
can only do it if i know i'm the butt of
the joke so like if joe's being a bully
we have to know that she's being stupid
and she's making a mistake that everyone
can see is a mistake because i don't
just like being mean and i think if the
joke is to be mean if not if everyone
isn't laughing then you're not that
funny so uh so yeah my goal with joe is
like when she's making mistakes to lean
into the mistake because some of the
stuff i say is brutal and otherwise i
don't think i could go home and be happy
with like as a human being knowing that
anyone's gonna be like i relate to her
i do have a question that when you are
in a moment where you're like just doing
stuff when the scene's over to you
almost feel like i am so sorry or is
everyone sort of understanding i love it
everyone's eating it
so it's great it's if anything i'm like
guys
i'm sorry but they're all like give us
more more
it's it's really fun we have a good uh
we all have fun with joe
does anyone else want to add or i uh
ended up in prison last year
so i mean that was thrilling as a as an
actor to be able to to do all these
things it's it's really fun i get to uh
i get to do a lot of things that i don't
normally get do in my everyday life my
son counts the number of swear words i
have per episode which is really fun
[Music]
is there a swear um yeah there's a
switch
there should be a square
is your son brad
yes
he's all about the money no but it's
that's that's the cool thing about
acting is that you want to be able to
try things you don't get to do in your
normal life yeah what's really fun this
season too is we get to see all these
different colors of dana's personality
because we like really set her up in
season one and two was being nice but
she she's not really nice she's kind
she's kind and so we get to see those
different layers of how she can you know
call out some bs if she spots it and she
gets a little sassy
do you find that um in when you meet
people in the video game industry and i
don't know if you do or don't that they
all want to tell you stories to like
incorporate like how much or do you not
meet anyone in the industry
i don't really meet anybody in the video
game industry i started in the video
game industry so i know a lot of folks
and i was a little disturbed how um
accurate our show was apparently i had a
lot of people being like
oh no i was triggered by your show like
i kind of can't watch it it's too real
and i was like oh no
there's actually a twitter thread um
there's a scene with sue in the first
season where she's speaking to a bunch
of little girls she's our community
manager
um and she's describing what it's like
to be a community manager um and it
started like a viral threat of community
managers in the game development
community being like this is the most
i'm like i feel attacked this is exactly
how i feel about my job so
we uh we got it uh right apparently
maybe a little too right but um yeah uh
we are at comic-con and i i really like
asking people what they obsess over so
if you actually have the time to walk
the convention floor what would you be
looking for who wants to start well i
went straight to the nickelodeon booth
because that orange just cost my soul
like
like a pacifier to a baby baby to a
pacifier fly to a flame
yeah i love nickelodeon but what i
obsess over is rupaul's drag race i've i
i'm a die hard fan i love it i look
forward to going to drag con one day and
that's the answer to what i obsess over
sessions uh i got to walk the floor it
was very exciting um
i loved going to the artist gallery i
liked doing those walks my uh
favorite comic right now is descender
and i got to meet the artist of
descender which is really cool dustin
one and that was really thrilling for me
oh i would say
comics and graphic novels right now i
got a really cool comic or graphic novel
yesterday and it's called wash day and
it's by
uh a black author and it's about four
women in their natural hair journey
which is like really cool that's so cool
um and i also go to the art session too
i probably look for sailor moon stuff if
i'm totally honest with you
oh i have something else to say because
i realized i was like what am i excited
about drag con i also like seeing people
dress up here yes
so fun
so fun what's crazy about the cosplay
here and i and i hear this from a lot of
actors and directors it's like the
sometimes the costumes are better than
what is on set especially when it's like
a last minute costume on set and it's
just amazing what people and they don't
have like the um the blueprints to do it
like they're looking no they just yeah
they just come up with it yeah it's i
mean it's it's a real talent it's
incredible you know yeah on that note
i'm just gonna say
i really love your show and uh i
obviously talked no specifics about the
new season except to say that i can't
wait to watch it and i really look
forward to talking to you guys again
once i've seen it to talk about
specifics um thank you so much for
coming by i really appreciate it thank
you thank you for watching our show
you